[Music]
in beauty and brains news beauty and sir
submitted my loyal Jamali ignite oh no
could I like the song and then tamale
for him got it
yeah good job guys beautiful team in LA
yeah oh I mean
good job guys Becky's a study finds that
good-looking experts are seen as more
interesting but less credible that's
true only only only believe in the Nerds
the ugly ones
why why why look too good I just want to
[ __ ] all right so good-looking experts
are less credible because is that
there's a correlation in their mind
between beauty and stupidity yes not for
me that's funny look at the Mexican
weather girl I can't be thinking about
the rain I'm just thinking about [ __ ]
dude that's what what is her name again
her Instagram not lovely but but then if
it's like a nerd then I'm like oh man
it's gonna rain tomorrow
damn the precipitation so hot that's
true every president is ugly as [ __ ]
yep hey Brock Obama yeah rock Obama or
McCain Brock Obama can be busted you not
for his heart but that's why he got
assassinated is because he was too sexy
oh is that light yep and he was banging
Marilyn Monroe pure jealousy not all was
a hot ass first lady and then everybody
was jealous the Queen of England was
like [ __ ] that that was ugly well why
did the queen of you yeah oh sorry
Castro wrong enemy yeah Castro from Cuba
he was like that mother father to
handsome [ __ ] him
and he was like I don't like that
competition time to kill ya what did the
UH stereotype for a blonde being dumb
come from it's not from like I don't
know that's a white people world maybe
just happens a lot maybe they just
blonde being dumb not now I mean
but don't they say gingers have no soul
yeah where did that come from - whose
name that's why people think yeah it's a
combination
I don't like crime it's white on white
crime okay
blonde baby that's white all white
racism because I bet if you talk to like
white people about Kay raised if I don't
know what that is ah the leis that's
some kind of k-pop is that another
Gangnam style Gangnam yes so there was a
study at the Cambridge University
Department of Psychology where they had
groups of participants look at photos of
more than 300 British and American
scientists and asked them to rate them
for their intelligence and
attractiveness those liked the first
part and then second part was where they
rated whether they were more interested
in the work that they did the scientists
did and then also to see like who
appeared more competent
so that's know what the glasses mm-hmm
100% yeah so it said the better-looking
and more sociable that they were
perceived to be the less they were
expected to conduct high quality
research what why maybe it's because if
you're focused on external things such
as your exterior look so much that's
probably a distraction for you you
really should be focusing on but that's
under it is the s alike that's under the
assumption that they take care of
themselves because there's some
naturally really beautiful people that
don't worry my gmail is Jimmy see some
of the pictures or they might say that
they [ __ ] her way to the top or
something Oh true they got there because
of this but we're assuming that it's all
women those men and women right
yeah the goddess - very handsome a dude
it's not - no way to the top I don't
think women I don't know why maybe I
don't feel like women are like so much
sexually enticed as men are cut is
already a misogynistic type of
environment all I'm saying is not the
attractive people's fault is just not
you on most Elon so there's a lot of
scientists that that they were that they
looked at so here's some of the examples
I don't know Elon Musk was a scientist I
just know Elon Musk who's this lady TV
program who do you think you are is
presented by biochemist Liz Bonnin
people who are more interested in
learning about the work of scientists
were seen as physically attractive
researchers found but who does be yeah
he said it um what is it
Lisa Liz bond Bannen what did she do
well can I get that I got it so I don't
think she's less credible yeah the joy
of data the curious cases of Rutherford
of fried features mathematician had a
fun Hannah frame she has no soul because
she's the right person
redhead person according to the
stereotype of ginger me that I might
obsessed with her hair it's so pretty
hers baby I like red hair how come
people think is bad I don't know I don't
know next one oh he looks smart that
Hugh Jackman he looks like Indiana Jones
how art made the world is presented by
classicist nigel spitty Nigel what is
that this is like a 1965 show as well as
it's like another good-looking scientist
he looks like he's about to find
diamonds
David Attenborough appearing on his TV
wildlife show zoo quest in 1956
oh Jessica I'm sorry I'm ruining it Wow
yeah so and this guy stuff will ugly I
don't know what they're talking about
thinking the same
he looks like an onion head oh [ __ ] he
looks like Stuart with an onion haircut
oh yeah you know it's just it's honestly
just the hair though look at that that's
pretty handsome well I think in the eyes
- oh maybe it is the hair sorry you know
I like it lipstick on hmm oh yeah it is
wow you guys are mean why call him ugly
you're golden eyes she's a TV presenter
and author Alice Roberts and experts in
anatomy and anthropology she's a
professor of public engagement in
science at the University of
bring'em it's interesting true though I
wish like they could also maybe there is
a study on how people perceive
intelligence as well you know what I
mean because there are a lot of people
out there who think they're very very
very smart but actually talk some of the
Dumber scoffs I've ever been like
[ __ ] life you know what I got a
question for you in
culture of the Aztecs like um is there
any type of stereotype behind dumb jock
if you're athletic you're [ __ ] dumb
because I'm Mexican I would know I don't
know in the culture of your traditional
Latin culture is there like a Latin or a
Texan which was Mexican make no I mean
Walt because it's very Western influence
so yeah attractive people are seen in
film because in agent culture I don't
think there's that stereotype of if you
look good
you're [ __ ] stupid see watch yourself
especially especially athleticism
they just because you're a jock or
athletic doesn't mean that you're
[ __ ] dumb we're very Western
influence you will get another loss or
whatever you'll have a really handsome
dude they could Judea that's kind of
just a mute I just think it's odd like
how people they like to value
intelligence very oddly you know they
like for example like they think that
somebody who is I guess quote-unquote
very well-read right but they're very
run-of-the-mill person they have really
done it made anything amazing in their
life but I obviously an intelligent
person but you look at somebody who's an
amazing basketball star he must be dumb
as [ __ ] but he's an expert in his craft
so who really is the dumb one here you
know it means this person has perfected
one amazing thing in their life and they
are at the upper echelon of what they do
so how is this person less intelligent
than you I don't you know you don't
anything yeah so it's kind of it's a
little bit odd for me it's a huge Fisher
I guess like intelligence is kind of
based on like how well-read you are or
you know I guess it just goes to show
you the person judging the intelligent
how smart they are look they're going to
look at an absolute and be like oh they
must be dumb
Oh God you could look at what we do
right and they're like well obviously
they clearly don't have a master's or
whatever what not so that's great but I
still make more money than you and
you're still watching my [ __ ] video
so suck my dick [ __ ] here you could say
that [ __ ] I wouldn't tell them bad
that's me
no I'm saying if they're good like I'm
just saying you don't mean I wish I
could see you can do your whole body's
good all I see is this is
that's it that's not like that's not to
say like what I'm thinking what I'm
saying is like if that's how people
perceive intelligence and skills like
how I don't know how it really works I
think I I I look at it more as are you
really good at what you do yeah
intensity you know so like even when
people are like oh I wish I could do
what you do on YouTube it's like well
yeah you could do what I do if this is
what you want but also at the same time
let's say you're an educator right
doesn't mean I could do what you do like
I would love to be able to protect my
crap in what you do but that's not where
my skills lie so everybody's
intelligence and skill is different
based on what you do like I wouldn't be
able to be a doctor I wouldn't be a
scientist I'm just a [ __ ] clown you
know I mean but I'm one of the best
clowns out there
you're a very good clown thank you
you're a great class thank you I love
being clowns that's the best job
occupation yeah you know just let people
be skilled at what they [ __ ] do man I
really do appreciate that because I
think it's very odd like I think when
people idolize like entertainers and
they're like I wish I had their life you
know what they're good at what they do
make you great at block their life
because a lot of entertainers got AIDS
and people understand ER working on oh I
don't I'm a clown your is it what do you
think it what is it what does a clown do
no an entertainer is on extra so that's
the leverage reporter well they're on
yeah they're like on the National
Enquirer the whole world knows who the
[ __ ] they are the whole world knows who
you are you're International do you okay
technically a wedding finger in a street
performer is an entertainer but not a
real entertainer I'm talking about the
top-notch entertainers the real
celebrity specific and they got AIDS all
of them they got [ __ ] AIDS
he's planning this one homeless Joe
again Joe I'm trying not to get AIDS
so I'm saying medium knowing level this
episode was brought to you by homeless
Joe Joe
not my point that I was making is that
if you're skilled at whatever you're
doing you're a [ __ ] genius that's
that and that's all man yeah don't
follow me about anybody else [ __ ] do
what you do I [ __ ] support you 100%
I wouldn't going on they can use fans
hope you guys like that episode remember
to follow our personal social media and
of course if you want to watch more
videos my friend she's nowhere to go
your gutters right up there
[Music]